The role of the costume designer is not only
to dress the actor but also to help define
the character the actor portrays.
They help paint each frame of the film and
their work can either contribute or distract
from the art the audience is experiencing.
A successful costume must be incorporated
by the story and be woven seamlessly into
the narrative and visual tapestry of the movie.
When you are adapting a superhero story into
a movie I is even harder due to the expectations
of the fans.
Here is Screen Rants list of 10 Superhero
Costume Designs That Could Have Ruined The
Movie.
Make sure to give us a thumbs up when we talk
about your favorite superhero.
Hugh Jackman as Wolverine
Director Sam Raimi wanted to make sure his
first X-Men venture was authentic to the comic
books, starting with the story line all the
way down to the costumes.
His original idea for Hugh Jackman’s Wolverine
costume was the yellow spandex we have grown
accustomed to in the comics.
He wasn’t the only one that was going to
wear their outfits in the comics; the entire
team was going to look like their original
designs.
Singer ultimately decided that the costumes
were too cartoonish and chose to go with the
sleek black costumes we saw in the movie.
Anthony Mackie as The Falcon
Anthony Mackie flew into 2014’s Captain
America: The Winter Soldier as The Falcon
and audiences loved him immediately.
His character, Sam Wilson was an expert aviator
due to his time as a military pararescue before
he joined the Avengers team so he fit well
into his superhero outfit.
The outfit you see in the films look like
a falcon but before the filmmakers settled
on those wings, they had another variation.
The prototype design looked more like an airliner
with jet engines on either side.
Maybe they would have renamed him The Aviator.
Anne Hathaway as Catwoman
Catwoman had numerous concepts drawn for her
role in The Dark Knight Rises, in and out
of superhero costume.
From her heels to her maid outfit they all
seemed to have changes but none more than
her Catwoman outfit.
The artists must have researched Tim Burton’s
Batman Returns because her original costume
had a much stronger resemblance to that film
and didn’t fit well in this Batman series.
Anne Hathaway looked great in all of her final
costumes and we probably couldn’t find much
reason to complain about her in any outfit.
Chris O'Donnell as Robin
Tim Burton directed the first two Batman films
and was ready to helm the third installment,
Batman Forever but the studio had a different
agenda.
Burton’s last installment was too dark for
the studio and they wanted to keep Batman
Forever family friendly.
The costume we saw Chris O'Donnell wear was
not the costume Burton had in mind for his
Robin, that was prepared for Marlon Wayans.
Burton’s costume had a mask that looked
like the Scarlet Witches mask and check out
the hair.
Jared Leto as the Joker
It seems that you can’t mention the film,
Suicide Squad without someone defending it
or complaining about it.
No matter what your opinion is you can see
that the concept art of Jared Leto’s Joker
was originally bland.
Initially he had no tattoos on his face and
no metal teeth and his costume was a simple
duster along with a dress shirt and a bow
tie.
The filmmakers decided to make Leto’s character
crazier and took his outfit and makeup to
the next level.
Interested in Harley Quinn’s costume changes?
Stick around and we’ll show you.
Ryan Reynolds as Deadpool
When you see Ryan Reynolds in 2016’s Deadpool
it is hard to believe that the team behind
that film was thinking of a different costume
than the one we saw in the film.
His final costume was perfect, his eyes showed
emotion and he wore his signature belt buckle.
The Merc with a Mouth was originally going
to wear a hockey-mask instead of his signature
mask and had straps holding the costume together.
This was a mediocre concept that everyone
should be glad that they decided against and
we’re sure Deadpool spoke out against it
too.
Jackie Earle Haley as Rorschach
Rorschach is a badass.
Period.
Jackie Earle Haley performed Rorschach perfectly
from his uncompromising code, ability to solve
mysteries and his love for killing bad guys.
Luckily his original costume was scrapped
or we would have been too distracted to enjoy
his performance.
Concept art of his original costume featured
bellbottoms.
That’s right, bellbottoms on the man that
makes a stop to the bathroom during a prison
escape to handle a little problem.
Stefan Kapicic as Colossus
It’s hard to say who was the actor behind
the character Colossus in the 2016, R-rated
superhero film, Deadpool.
It took five different actors to actually
create the CGI version of this character with
Stefan Kapicic performing the voice.
Colossus was a big mutant made of organic
steel but despite being made of steel and
CGI he had great expressions.
The original costume concepts for this character
were hidden behind a hood.
It’s a lot more fun to see his expressions
during battle and when listening to Deadpool’s
loving commentary.
Tobey Maguire as Spider-Man
When Sam Raimi started pre-production on 2002’s
Spider-Man he hired one of the greatest comic
book artists of all time to work on costume
concepts, Alex Ross.
Ross’s drawings were not aligned with Raimi’s
vision.
For starters the costume was much darker,
which would have brought a bleaker tone to
the film.
Still, one of the biggest problems with his
work was Spider-Man’s eyes, they were dome-shaped
and extruded from the front of his costume.
This concept might have worked for a real
spider but not for the heroic Peter Parker.
Margot Robbie as Harley Quinn
There is no denying that Margot Robbie stole
the show in 2016’s Suicide Squad, hence
why thousands of woman dressed as her for
Halloween.
Maybe they wouldn’t have if they used the
original concepts for Harley Quinn’s costume.
They originally wanted to have a tattoo of
the Joker’s face on her chest and the word,
“puddin” across her crotch.
Her entire stomach would have been shown and
half her breasts too.
If the filmmakers thought they were given
a hard time about sexualizing Robbie in this
film, imagine how bad it would have been if
they used the concept costumes.
What do you think of our video?
Did we skip over any other costume designs
that would have ruined the movie?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more fun videos!
Don’t forget to watch another awesome video
from Screen Rant by picking one now.
Thanks for watching!